okay hey hello and welcome to this video
playing Grand Master Eric Cooper at bird
one of the frequent opponents come on
you're not yeah you're not playing III
or z3m go for something sharp as usually
does yeah this is a somewhat
controversial line for sure a4 here I
think I can play before I mean black is
moving the Queen a million times this is
a very sharp way of doing it okay if
this is really risky for black phone I'm
doing him I have very bad development
and it's it's the kind of thing that can
blow up in your face pretty badly okay I
think I do this ephi v6 is the problem
like e51 if I'm getting like to move
their Bishop g7 didn't okay I don't we
will see i mean it is dangerous anyway
but for this doesn't feel that critical
to me if I'm perfectly honest am okay
he's preventing me from challenging the
night
it's difficult to play this without
getting rid of his night absolutely some
is six maybe I mean this is this is
tough maybe some is six if he goes f5
this is also very tough now 595 should
probably be okay even though this is
difficult to assess I want to play you
sexy and this position and then possibly
take or if he takes Bishop takes and
then I can take it takes you for many as
we can disk inside also quite a bit oh
very hard maybe just rookie won this
kind of the kind of the Stewart
stereotypical idea so I put this book
into the game but it's taking a while so
maybe he's thinking about something more
enterprising like 'if I've takes f5 for
things like that that's also quite a
normal motif
and it's kind of strange he sometimes
takes longer longer thinks but this is
very very long no we both have a
connection so he's just thinking for a
very long time probably five then
[Music]
that's strange maybe that's some other
technical glitch you might be connected
but something else going on I would be a
bit of a shame because this position is
very interesting it really is yeah so he
ultimately decided to fire so is there
anything else but taking I don't think
so so let's take it yeah that was kind
of clear that must have been the idea so
what to do king is threatening to break
through them before as an intermediate
move that could make sense no it doesn't
make sense check so is that really what
he calculated that would be deeply
impressive possible it's possible I mean
so I hear hear I mean is this bad for me
he's a while
not material up here
[Music]
Wow 96 oh great those this move took me
far too long check just wanted to peek
in the bishop there so that I'm
attacking it 95 doesn't work time
morning maybe I should come eat six
actually yeah don't like it that much
but okay i'm happy for now as an idea
timewise i'm quite ok and ok ok wait it
is a threat so check let's take it push
96 ok ok five
try to get to six and we're not getting
something some of those pawns here casa
it was a check passer what I did k
bishop if two will attack the pawn so
can I do something interesting like
maybe I activate the young lady I will
check the pawn check an ID for is
escaping to opposite color check bishops
in check can I can I do something
probably not white forfeits and time and
it's probably a winner it's a winnie
actually well I said thank you it's
automatic thank you knowing okay that
pushed me over 2,500 that's cute ok so
let's get analysis on Nettles really
tough time as usual
playing this aggressive style of play
yeah this is really dangerous for
blackie i mean my asthma development
this is not great yeah I don't know h5
but the danger is set like something
like this is totally destroying my
structure ok this one and I am the
engine is who but this is also looking
very dangerous and this this surprised
me but so this was what I feared because
I felt I probably cannot take somehow
like with this so on gathered that that
actually does not seem to be so great
but the computer now finds night g5 whoa
I mean I have no development so I'm not
surprised and this yeah this is this is
really weird and here black has to be
worse I mean a lot worse yeah that's
terrible yeah I added something wrong
there in the opening my he again 85 him
and Bishop before something that I kind
of regret it later I think probably here
to have this also if he beats place this
mission 86 I have to get rid of this
night and this would also make my bishop
much more effective the computer gives
equal funny enough yeah maybe maybe it
still feels very dangerous out here now
it took like two minutes em to play this
and it's just I found how the decent
defense Queenie one
this this and now at least I'm not lost
languages which is some accomplishment
took me a long time Bishop f5 check
probably this is really some what I mean
maybe inside at a fan but here this
should should be equal it's a reasonably
good game i think not not there were no
check big blunders this should end in a
draw at ok its chances typical time time
to scramble thing ok guys thanks for
watching